and if I read philosophy I tend not to
read second-rate philosophy and so I've
tried to avoid the postmodernist to some
degree because they're there in
coherency is one of the least of their
sins but they don't care about that no
no you got understand man it's
modernists and Enlightenment people and
even traditionalists who care about
coherency the post modernists don't
believe in coherency they don't believe
and I'm not making this up this is part
of their philosophy they don't believe
in logic you know this Derrida says
straight out that Western society is
fallow log old centric by which he means
male-centered and privilege the idea of
logic well he doesn't buy any of that he
doesn't think that there's a truth it's
out there he doesn't believe that
individuals can reach any sort of truth
by thinking he certainly doesn't believe
that we can move towards truth in
dialogue because out style logic right
there's none of that you wonder well why
don't the part of the postmodern types
keep other thinkers off the campus well
it's not because they're afraid well so
some of them are but they use their
fragility as a mask for their you know
the underlying philosophical your
underlying philosophical and political
interests they do that fragmentarily
it's not like every social justice
warriors a you know sword carrying
postmodernist but the ideas are
fragmented and distributed among them
like they're distributed among a mob and
if you put the whole mob together you
get the whole post modernist thing
happening at the same time and that's
how ideas have people instead of the
other way around
anyways forget about logic that's out
the window that's just a construct of
Western society and the whole point of
the construct was to impress other
people and to take their wealth and to
privilege the people who live within
that so-called logic system so that they
can justify to themselves and other
people their predator rapaciousness
straight and simple and that's partly
because post-modernism was influenced by
Marxism and of course that's what the
Marxist think about any situation where
there's a let's call it a power status
differential the people at the top are
only there because they've stole
everything from the people at the bottom